yeah I heard you do this thing that's
almost like Holiday the movie you do
like a you swap houses yeah so we we are
part of like a
um we signed up for this like home
exchange uh I would say Collective or
Community but then it sounds like I'm an
occult I mean it's like you know we just
uh it's anyway it's one of those it's a
home exchange Community okay and you pay
a fee and then it kind of self-filters
you have to be recommended and it's all
people who work my husband's in
advertisers all people who work in
advertising and design so usually
someone knows someone who knows someone
kind of a thing yeah so the creepy
factor is not 100 and um and it's in
design their house is probably cool no
it's actually a lot of times I'm like oh
we can't exchange with them their place
is way way too nice they're gonna be
horrified when they come to our house
yeah so um but we've done it a few times
we do it with an Italian family and a
Spanish family and it's so cool because
like it makes the world so small yeah
it's all sort of you know swap usually
the kids are around the same age range
and we'll like set up you know the like
just basic stuff like oh the good good
place for pizza for kids is this place
but for grown-ups yeah it's better than
like trip I mean TripAdvisor is great
but like it gives you that it just gives
you that Hands-On thing and then I mean
like in the Italian one it was hilarious
like we woke up you know the first day
there got settled and like the Italian
kids were in my house playing fortnite
on our computer and my son was playing
Italian fortnite on their computer you
know and it was just one of those like
it just made the world feel really
lovely and small in a nice way it is
also known you have kids and like we're
at the beach and I'm like bro why do you
have your iPad right now like there is
an ocean in front of you turn it off
yeah I'm like how did it even get down
here I'm like what are you doing I know
yes
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
okay